foreign
mixed I was put up for adoption at Birth
and they're both white they don't speak
Spanish at all and what I've noticed is
since I look Mexican a lot of uh
Hispanic people expect me to speak
Spanish
or fit in with the culture somehow and I
don't
[Music]
hey what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show so glad that you are
with us talking about mental health and
parenting and relationships and marriage
kids school whatever you got going on
we'll talk about your pets if that would
help uh I'm not great what are you what
are you waving questions for humans
I thought you were flipping me off
that's what you you are not good at like
subtlety and like hints and like hey
don't forget we have to do this and I
hold it up
I'm not good at subtlety
but that's not shocking it's not my wife
tells me that like it's like been an
embarrassing thing for 20 years like
you're like the one where you know like
I can see Sheila's trying to kick you
under the table and you're like why are
you kicking me yes or like hey you don't
need to be around this person because
they want to date you and I'm like what
are you talking about you're in yeah I
the most clueless yeah I don't have a
lot of friends it's cool but we love you
oh do we do you we do oh
um like a labrador okay so hey if you
want to be on the show and clearly it's
it's one of the best
um as seen by how we're launching this
this morning
give me a buzz dude 184
1-844-693-3291
1-844-693-3291 we have a packed house
out there today packed
packed
we got three awesome folks one dude on
his phone good to see you man or maybe
you're texting you're texting me I'll
holler back at you all right so we're
doing questions for humans yes because
oh so ten dollars it's the May ten
dollars to you and all of the questions
for humans are ten dollars
so we're gonna you know how much they
ask me before they put all my stuff on
sale no whatever
it's cool though it's cool
all right so go for it all right so I
didn't pref preface anyone with this
question sorry
Lord help me all right how old do you
feel like you really are and why
it's a great question go first Jenna
why is it always me first
um
I feel
maybe like 30. I feel like sometimes I
feel like I'm like
more mature wiser or like I have to be
like the mother of a group and my
friends so I always feel like I'm like
even though I'm typically the youngest
one in my friend group I I genuinely
feel like I'm the older one and I was
gonna say because you're always like
singing Taylor Swift as you skip down
the Halls that you're like 13. yes
that's exactly me yeah that's so good
although I do love me some T Swift but I
don't tend to skip down the Halls
although I can if you want I'm not a
haul Skipper Ben what do you say
it's a it's a little bit of a two-part
emotionally I feel like 22. okay
physically I feel like 40. my bones
Creak all the time knees joints pop all
the time yeah I just throw down at a
hardcore show like yourself not get
better as you get older just heads up
all right what do you say Kelly
um
I would say
I feel
like closer to late 30s early 40s
and I'm
about to be 49 and because you're old
go ahead two years older than me people
three years
um because I feel I keep feeling like
there's got to be other people that are
more adult than me
like I can't be the adult and especially
now like since my mom passed we have
none of our aunts and uncles on that
side of the family so we cousins are the
old ones are you know we're the oldest
now we're like wait us oh crap I think
that's the great secret to adulthood
when you realize that all the people
that you thought had together were
making it up nothing yeah it's clear
like my parents had no clue what they
were doing no making it up yeah makes
you feel better but yeah I keep I still
feel like there's got to be somebody
that's more of an adult than me see I'm
trapped between
I
based on some text messages messages I
sent this morning my humor locked in at
about 14 and just stopped it just parked
there
and kind of like you're talking James
like the other night after a hardcore
show like I'm James sorry Ben the other
day after that show my body was like
we're getting pretty old for the old
mosh pits I remember being a kid in the
pit being like who's that old guy and it
occurred to me the other night oh that's
mean that's you I'm that guy I wasn't
wearing like a suit jacket though but
but yeah
um yeah I think 14 and uh
45 just like uh Jennifer what's the
movie
who was the woman who played Alias 13
going on 30. oh yeah
um
Jennifer Garner yes yes
I kind of feel like that so there you go
questions for humans
oh nay dog
uh I feel like I'm in my mid to late 30s
I'm actually 32 but I feel older because
I have four children that sap most
energy I could ever possibly accumulate
ever
that's the saddest answer I just feel
like I'm done way to bring the room down
Nathan hi I'm I'm the father of four
this is it
it's true it's true awesome all right
question for humans let's go out to uh
James in h-tone what's up James
hey Dr John thanks for taking my call I
really appreciate it of course man
what's up
hey so first things first go Astros have
to get that in there yeah dude they are
not going very fast right now no but
there's a lot of games so we're good
smoking like a true Astro fan okay
there's a lot of games ahead so what's
up Hey so uh relationship question for
you
um I'll just get right to it and then
give you a few bullet points
so how do I set boundaries with my
brother-in-law who is getting a divorce
from my sister that'll keep me healthy
emotionally
did he leave is he leaving your sister
uh I mean that's kind of
getting I mean he's the one that filed
but I mean there's always more to it you
know so what's what tell me more to it
so
um
their relationship or what I'm calling
about yeah what you're calling about
okay so I'll give you a few bullet
points so
in uh January they filed for divorce and
so just kind of out of respect for them
I uh I didn't talk to him much
um I mean there's attorneys involved and
just to support my sister 100 and just
out of respect so
um like I said didn't talk with him much
until last week
um he sent me some texts kind of
emotionally charged and I had abandoned
him and
he didn't know what I was getting at by
not talking to him and just sort of
guilt-tripping me a little bit so I
responded and
eventually I just said hey let's just
meet up for lunch and talk about it
thank you for being the adult in the
room
well I mean I kind of gave in for a few
texts but eventually I mean that's like
super Dawson's Creek Avril Lavigne like
you're not my friend anymore I'm sending
a mean text it's like bro you're adults
man just like let's speed up but good
for you okay
it was good it was good
um it was productive I told him hey
nothing's out of spite I just I gotta
support my sis you know she's
um I mean her husband's leaving her
dad's not really in the picture I'm the
only brother so I just want to be there
for however I can we see mature adult
and and hear that out
yes yeah he actually did it's not what
he wanted to hear yeah um
but he said okay I mean that hurts but
I'm gonna follow your lead moving
forward
so I said hey I can't give you a time
frame and I know it's unfair but I'm
treading out familiar Waters here you
know I I don't think there's anything
unfair about it to be honest with you
um
I know that that marriages go two-way
well I know marriages go two ways
there's always two sides to a story and
sometimes the person who finally just
calls it
um is the bad guy right
um
and so he may not be the bad guy here it
may just be who knows what's going on
but at the end of the day you get to
decide who you're you are in
relationship with and similar if you had
called and said hey this is like one of
my closest friends in the world we we've
we're our our families play together we
we are go out all the time
and I'm not going to lose my friendship
just because him and my sister didn't
work out and my sister's having a bad
attitude about it I would tell you she
didn't get a vote either
what you need to know is whatever you
decide is going to come with a cost and
just be okay with that
I say be okay with it it's not like it's
gonna be fun but at the end of the day
um be okay with it I know some folks who
have
um
filed for divorce and they imagine the
other side of divorce as though
everything on their life is the same
they just removed the one
um puzzle piece that was their husband
or wife and then just replaced it with
somebody who's more fun and cool and
prettier and younger or whatever
but they think that their friends are
going to stay the same they're they're
living arrangements are going to stay
the same and so I it's it never ceases
to amaze me how surprised people are
that when you file for divorce when you
marriage when your marriage breaks up
when you choose to call out on your
marriage it affects everything it blows
up your friendship circles it blows up
where you hang out it usually affects
your living Arrangement your income it
blows up everything
and so
um he's going to want to try to hang on
to every bit of this is the way my life
used to be and not take full
accountability for it no dude everything
you know about your former life is over
now and you're going to figure out what
comes next see what I'm saying and
that's not your that's not your
responsibility to Carrie
the the other side of this is this as
your sister said I don't want you
talking to him I don't want you meeting
with him I don't want him in in your
life
no no she's she knows we're all going to
have to figure out her relationship with
him moving forward so why'd you choose
this why'd you why is your solution I
gotta cut him out
well I mean it's not cut out completely
I mean I
uh I just don't want to say something
that might be used for I don't know
maybe the attorneys or something like
that and and to be honest with you it
was kind of taxing emotionally
to see him you know break down while I
was talking to him and then
talk to my sister and see her breakdown
and I just feel like being in the middle
of it is it brings me though you know
yeah dude hold on hold on man you're in
relationship with these people is your
sister and your best friend
like this is what this is what we do
when we have family members and best
friends we get in the mud with them
like if you only want to be around have
friends and family members unless
they're not bumming me out bro dude that
makes you not a great friend and not a
great brother or sister
like it of course is going to bring you
down and that's why you're there like
that that's the role you play in the
season is sitting with people in their
grief the picture they had for their
life is is exploded it's gone and that's
what friends and Community does and so I
I guess I would challenge you man
um
to not see this like man it's just kind
of bumming me out bro like I I just I
don't know I don't know I don't identify
with that I attitude at all
I want to be there for my friends when
they're hurt and bad
I got you and I get
um you're not wanting to say something
dumb hopefully you're
you trust yourself enough to not do that
maybe you don't maybe you don't but what
do you think you're gonna say
um I don't know maybe something that my
sister has told me that he doesn't know
about or
I don't know it
like I said this is unfamiliar to me
um so one one important thing let me
tell you a couple of things that guide
my life okay maybe this helps number one
especially in this situation I don't
keep secrets I'm out
I don't keep secrets so if someone's
like hey I need to tell you this but you
can't nope I'm out I don't want to hear
that that's for you and your attorney
um I'm not I'm not the person When the
Smoke Clears and all this we can talk
but right now it's not smart the um the
second part is my buddies know my
closest friends in the world now
if they leave their wives I'll love them
I will I will love them to the end of
time but their wife is welcome at my
house then come stay with me now they
don't have to and if they don't want to
then my buddies can come stay too but
I'm not going to just go to war against
their spouse because they they chose to
make decisions
because their spouse is one of my close
friends too and I'm talking about my
court my core group of people
um and so
I think you can do both
but also I'm not worried about
accidentally saying something that I
shouldn't be saying or I I I'm I'm a
pretty good Vault of a friend and so I'm
not worried about saying this or saying
that like ads it sounds like at the end
of the day brother there's you need to
be confident in your emotional maturity
and maybe this is the first big heavy
thing that you've experienced with your
friends and your family but
unfortunately dude this is the rest of
your life marriages are gonna blow up
your friends are gonna do stupid stuff
your friend's gonna go to jail you're
gonna get fired from your job someone's
gonna pass away this is the future and
so being able to handle that in a
dignified way that honors people's
confidentiality that doesn't just write
people and cut people out
um that doesn't just like you hide
because man you're making me feel bad
because you're sad of course that's
that's when friends go in that's when
friends go in when the building's on
fire
um
that was tough man but I want you to
reconsider your role in their lives
they've been leaning on you y'all been
together for Seasons just like this
[Music]
season's just like this
if you can't do it at least yeah good
for you you know enough about yourself
to know I can't do that but my hope is
can head into the storm instead of
running away from it thanks for the call
Brother we'll be right back
[Music]
hey Delona here folks getting out of
debt and getting good sleep have
something in common intentionality when
you're working your way out of debt you
have to be purposeful you got to build
your emergency fund pay off your debt
smallest to largest and stick with it
all that stuff and when you're ready to
invest in good sleep you have to have a
plan too you gotta get that early
morning sunlight you gotta exercise you
gotta cut out all this caffeine and you
gotta limit screen time and you have to
budget for a premium quality mattress
because it makes an enormous difference
and that's why I recommend dream Cloud
mattresses and for my friends on a
budget I have incredible news right now
dream Club is offering my listeners 25
off their order plus 50 in additional
savings and why not 599 more dollars in
accessories with promo code John deloney
that's pillows luxury sheets and a
mattress protector and dream Cloud gives
you a one year in-home trial so you can
make sure it's the right fit so it's
time to invest in good sleep have a
budget meeting with your spouse make a
plan and then go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney to get your
new mattress today that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and use code John
deloney
all right we are back let's go to Ashley
in San Clemente California what's up
Ashley
how are you good how are you
doing all right all right
[Music]
um
I'm wondering how I can better connect
with women after being raised by a
narcissistic letter
and now I have two boys and I'm in a new
community and just I'm finding it really
hard
to maintain friendships with women it
just seems as if it's not going anywhere
I'm just really happy-go-lucky and it
seems as if people are just getting
bored of me and I can't keep friendships
with people
why do you think that
give me some evidence that that's true
that people that you are happy go lucky
and they just get bored of you
and walk away
people seem happy to keep talking me
keeping up getting acquaintances of
sorts but after a while of meeting up
with our kids and whatnot it just dies
out
and it seems as if that's the case with
a lot of friendships that I have made
here so far and I start to think it's
not them it's me it's and I
that's fair have you tried having people
over in your home
I have
it has it hasn't worked out tell me
about it
yeah it's it's worked out people are
really happy we have a huge yard the
kids all the kids come over and
we have people
the kids enjoy it our kids play well
um you know I can keep a conversation
going I
we're having a good time but then it
just seems as if maybe they connect with
the other moms more or and they go off
and do their own thing at some point and
I'm just
waiting
to see if
they're going to call or they're going
to text or
yeah I I mean another example is I'm a
part of this support group at a farm for
parents and all the children are there
too and I do have a friend there and she
tried to be vulnerable with me and I
just I can't get myself to be
comfortable enough to say more than I'm
here for you I'm sorry you're going
through this that's really tough
and then she went on to express this her
situation at the support group and I
just watched all these women gather
around her and they're just saying
really honest and beautiful things that
things that I feel like I
had wanted to tell her but I just my
body just feels I know you talk about
this a lot just
your body just my body just really feels
unsafe
yeah being vulnerable with people
so can I tell you you're you're right
there on the edge of this whole thing
turning around for you
what you just said is really powerful
hold on I want you to know how far you
come
you're talking years of counseling and
therapy to get to right where you said
right where you just articulated
the words are in your heart the words
are on your tongue you're ready to and
your body freezes up on you because when
you're a kid that level of vulnerability
got you hurt
right
yeah and my guess is there's probably
other romantic relationships that have
cycled through that as well Fair
foreign
not exactly because I you know I
I was the person to
leave people before I could be
vulnerable
with that that's what I mean as I'm
talking about the cycle like this whole
cycle period yeah so
all I have to say is this you're at a
precipice
and you get to choose what comes next
and
just don't know how to do that
you gotta jump
I wish there was another way around it
the the the the old DBT pathway is
there's a negative thought or a negative
trigger and it's all these women crowded
it's a friend of yours who's weeping
right and it automatically free freezes
your body up and maybe it's because when
Mama would start crying you knew oh God
here we go she's gonna drag me under
water and make me feel this way in that
way whatever
and that leads to negative emotions I
feel this thing and then I I act in
sometimes the negative action is don't
act sometimes just run and grab a drink
sometimes just go run and grab a a donut
sometimes it's freeze
I do nothing I let my friend just stand
out there in the cold
and then the fourth and I think this can
be the worst part of it all is the
negative emotions you internalize after
whatever action you do or don't do
yeah and then you beat yourself up about
it and the whole Loop starts over again
right yeah that's what this past two
weeks I've been like I just left
afterwards we're supposed to Coffee I
just left and packed my kids up and went
in the car and just thought I shouldn't
even
have friends like
I don't want to be I mean just this is
Extreme but you know I was just
reverting to my
child self and I just thought I don't
even want to be alive I just I don't
know why people need me their lives are
why I'm here or
and it's so extreme but
I just
felt that lonely child self come back
and hold force and just started blaming
myself because I'm an adult now and I
have kids and just feels like I
shouldn't be doing this anymore right
but you don't have to run away but I am
and it just feels
immature and stupid do you want to be
different that listen listen hold on
hold on
the way you're talking to yourself
that's your mom's words coming out of
your mouth at that seven-year-old little
girl stop
no don't let your mom keep talking into
your life
yeah okay
she didn't get a voice anymore
and I know that's easy to say in a short
phone call what this will mean is
several months
of you catching that voice every single
solitary time you hear it every time
I'm in the middle of this right now and
I'm telling you
it is the worst
every time I have a negative thought
negative self-talk and I am ruthless
with myself
um and I thought I could hide it on the
show and enough people called it out and
then sitting with a counselor like it's
bad it's not good
and catching it every single time and
challenging it what I'm telling you
already in my life is it's already
starting to fade
it's already starting to fade
here's what I want you to articulate for
me what is stopping you from reaching
out to her
and
saying hey you had a moment of
vulnerability
and I froze I'm so glad all those other
women were there but I want to Circle
back and check in with you how are you
doing now
what's stopping you from that that phone
call that conversation that cup of
coffee
because I I think I think you're that
close to developing a deep deep
friendship with somebody
I mean I'm about to do that
um but you promise you'll do that for
the day's over
I will I'm just really scared of how
that conversation is going to go yes
afterwards
and if I'm going to be rejected or if
she's just going to play it off and say
like oh totally fine now do you think do
you think she even even noticed
that I left or that I didn't respond
my guess is she didn't even notice I
don't think she did
okay
when you are surrounded or raised or
worked for narcissist you you put your
head on a swivel 24 7 365 because you
never know where it's going to come from
we know bad guys are going to try to
hurt us and we know that uh fire will
burn us but when somebody who's
reportedly loves us
hurts us right it comes from it comes
from all angles and so
I oh you're so hyper aware I would bet
beyond anything
um
that she she certainly doesn't feel the
same way you do about it she's not
staying at home right now being like Oh
my gosh Ashley failed me she screwed up
so bad and then she just ran away I
almost guarantee you she's not doing
that
okay
and here's the thing
a hundred percent of relationships are a
risk all of them yeah I've been married
for 20 years and we dated five years
before that
every day is a risk
starting a new friendship is a risk what
does that mean she could say yeah I'm
good man are you gonna come over for
coffee no I'm good I don't want to hang
out
and by the way if she says that she may
have diarrhea
it may not she may not be saying no
because she doesn't like you and you're
somewhere you know and so maybe the
second or third time she says no and
then
okay I get the message this hurts I'm
gonna be sad about it
and then I'm gonna go on
I and let me answer your question you
asked earlier I think you have the
opportunity to be such a powerful gift
to your kids and to other women in your
life
what you're hiding behind the garage
door is so uh important for people
so important
well thanks for everything I'm not I'm
not just making it up
because you've seen
people who are supposed to love you hurt
people
all of us have but most of us don't have
a vocabulary a language a relationship
to talk about that in you've got that
it's gift you can share that
because so it's just no don't guess how
it is it is
listen I um I'm terrified of heights
with all of my life
like for for my whole life I don't like
getting on ladders I don't like uh I
don't like I I just hate it I hate
heights
and then my buddy my boss
peer pressure just all into going
skydiving
and there's like no way I'm doing this
and then a couple of my colleagues
instantly said no I'm not doing it and I
was like well then for sure I'm doing it
then because I'm still middle schooler
when it comes to peer pressure and so I
went
and I got all and the guy who I was
Tethered to some big old tatted up smoke
show former Navy SEAL guy and he looked
at me and said you're gonna try to fight
me as we go out the door we're going out
that door
the easier you want to make this the
better and then he said these words you
just gotta jump
and then I did
and I'll tell you it was Transcendent it
was it was uh just did not get too
cheesy as a spiritual moment the whole
world slowed down
right
yeah when it comes you were right there
you know your body's responding you know
how nervous you get you know how
comfortable you get
you gotta jump
and then when you go you gotta feel it
and I know you will but be cognizant of
it right this is a trigger for me it's
creating negative emotions which makes
me act a certain way or it doesn't make
me but it propels me into a different
kind of action and then I feel bad about
the way I just acted it just goes in a
circle on a circle in a circle and any
one of those points you can jump in
there and stop that cycle it's awesome
my body's feeling bad it shouldn't feel
that way yes it should it should my mom
sucked my mom was really not a great
person and and goofed me up from the
get-go now my body's doing what it
should be but I really want friends and
This Woman's hurting I'm gonna I'm gonna
lean in
that's how we go man we break that cycle
and we're gonna do it over and over and
over and over because that Cycle's super
entrenched and your kids are going to
get to watch their mom
breathe for the first time in a long
time
I was talking to somebody the other day
who's struggling in their marriage and
they track all their sleep and
everything and she was telling me that
when her and her husband have been
reconnecting not sexually just
reconnecting just like hanging out
laughing talking uh telling story
whatever just reconnecting
um that all of our metrics are better
heart rate's a little bit slower
throughout the day sleep is a little bit
deeper throughout the evening it just
has a ripple effect through a person's
physiology
so you're gonna you're gonna bring peace
to your home
when you just jump
you're worth friends my sister you're
worth friends and thank you for calling
let me know how this conversation goes
if you'll write me back in because
people are going to want to know how
this uh this coffee played out we'll be
right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to Mary in
Bakersfield California what's up Mary
hi what are you doing I'm great what are
you doing
I'm in my car I'm at work but I took a
little time aside to talk to you that's
fantastic do you look like a like a
phone creeper like in the car are they
gonna walk by and be like what's Mary
doing
I don't think so I don't see anybody
right now
right now we have a covert okay good all
right so what's up
um well when I emailed your your show I
was talking about
um
how um I'm racially mixed I was born to
a Mexican mother and a white father okay
um they couldn't take care of me on
their own so I was put up for adoption
at Birth
um the family that um
took me in as my foster parents they
they adopted me officially at age when I
was four
and they're both white uh both from Ohio
they don't speak Spanish at all and what
I've noticed is
since I look Mexican I've noticed that a
lot of uh Hispanic people expect me to
speak Spanish
or fit in with the culture somehow and I
don't
and um I've never felt
comfortable in my own skin about it like
um where I work I work on the east side
of town
and it's uh I guess I'd say 90 Spanish
speaking and um
sometimes the reactions I get from
people
who are not speaking Spanish it's like
they think I'm a traitor or like like I
um
like I'm going against my race and they
though obviously they don't know my
story sure and it's really honestly it's
hurtful I get really hurt by by the the
judgment and um and honestly I've I've
met my my mother's family I met them
about 22 years ago and I have a half
brother on that side
and um I I hear I hear people talk about
how Mexican families are so close
but this one isn't and they're they're
just they're backstabbing and I assume
that way they they treated my mother I
never got to meet her she died before I
could meet her and I see the way they
treated her and my brother
and I can see why they weren't there
and it hurts yeah
we can we can walk through the
um racial and ethnic identity stuff okay
yeah but at the core here
I I see how old are you Mary
uh 47 47.
yeah I just see a beautiful young woman
lost at sea
and I see a beautiful young woman lost
at sea who doesn't like herself
and I want to ask you
forget the voices
the voices that are asking you why did
your mom and dad
uh uh but yeah for adoption why did you
get raised by a white family in Ohio why
do people in your neighborhood
constantly tell you you're not enough
you're too much whatever
take those voices aside for a second
that's hard I know those voices are hard
why don't you like Mary
um
I don't I wouldn't say that I don't like
myself I just don't
I don't like how people treat me it's
usually other Mexicans that treat me
this way like I'm not Mexican enough and
they they don't they know I know that
changes that but but but the fact that
that voice gets into your soul so much
well that's the side that rejected me
the Mexican side they reject my Mexican
Mother's family did not
take me in if it wasn't for my grandma
there we go hold on hold on hold on
let's go race a lot let's don't
racialize this okay okay
your mom's family said they don't want
anything to do with you
and that hurts let's sit on that for a
second
because what I don't want to do is I
don't want to take a paintbrush and
paint the entire Mexican culture because
you said Mexican films are supposed to
be like X and mine is like why
then what you're doing is you're doing
the exact same thing that those people
in your community are doing to you
they're looking at you and saying well
you should be like this and that's not
fair to do let's just look at this
family
that is choosing actively
to not be in your life we can't run from
that let's sit in that for a minute
because it hurts so bad
and if we avoid that grief
with all this other stuff the other
stuff is real the ethnic identity and
the racial that's all real
but when we avoid that hurt by this this
this
oh man
it's heavy
and what about your bios dad's family
um I found
that and they believe it or not most of
them live in Arkansas
I don't know why is that funny
uh well because it's a it's a weird
story I I haven't found him but I
I did track down
uh relatives in Arkansas through the DNA
test okay why haven't you reached that
you reached out to him
I I can't find them they they don't know
where he is either and I I won't get
into that but okay okay
um but anyway I mean they've been good
about it I mean it's and my my mother's
family hasn't been all bad but I've seen
the way they not only treated my mother
when she was alive I've seen the way
they treat each other and if it hadn't
been for my maternal grandparents my
brother my my brother that I mentioned
he probably would have been put in the
Foster system too
by the time I came along they were too
old to take on an infant and nobody else
stepped up that my mother came from a
large family she was number number nine
out of ten children and somebody could
have stepped up and taken me and they
just didn't and that that right there
Mary
that's where you go to park
I can hear that your voice changes you
got so much anger there
yeah
they should have
yeah and now 47 year old Mary is
choosing to cut her life short with high
blood pressure and increased heart rate
and not sleeping and goofed up
relationships because you won't put that
anger down they should have shown up and
they didn't
and the question you've got to ask
yourself is am I going to continue to
carry that around like a sack of bricks
on my shoulder or am I going to set that
crap down
I have a little girl she's seven
I can't imagine taking a breath of my
life without her anymore
and I can't even identify with what you
experienced as a kid I can't I can't
wrap my head around it
do you have kids of your own
no okay
here's why I think you need to spend
some time with do I like Mary
it's really common
for people who have experienced what
you've experienced
even though it sounds nuts
there's a five or six or seven year old
little girl wondering
what is so wrong with me
what did I do
and I want to tell you you did nothing
your mom and dad your bio mom and dad
had stuff going on in their life that
had nothing to do with you and you got
you were a casualty of it
your extended family on both sides
that stuff going on in their life had
nothing to do with you you were a
casualty of it I'm so sorry
um
I grew up I spent my whole life except
for the last five years in Texas
and so I there was a I think it was in
the 80s maybe 70s or 80s there was a
swath of I grew up around Mexican and
Hispanic people that's my that's my
that's my life and
um
there was a whole movement to not speak
Spanish in the home
and I've got many friends who are a
little bit who are younger than you but
uh not by a lot who's are so just pissed
that their parents didn't teach them
Spanish to teach them part of culture
and it's become this cool adventure not
a you should you should be not like that
that kind of pressure solves no problems
right it just creates gas like like like
uh like indigestion gas
but an adventure to find out huh how far
does a string go
and you've been on Ancestry so you've
been you've been digging right yeah yeah
for years yeah
so I think
once you can start digging not out of
desperation to find out where I come
from but in a spirit of adventure and a
spirit of
I want to explore this
now you got a whole there's a whole
different attitude towards it and then
maybe one maybe one day uh let me ask
you this this is a hard question
are you embarrassed that you can't speak
Spanish
no I mean I've taken Spanish classes and
I'm not
um
are you embarrassed that you can't speak
Spanish yes or no
yes why
well because it's like that's right
well I mean I would like I wish I could
identify
with the Mexican side I wish the thing
is growing up I didn't have that parent
to identify with I didn't have like what
other ethnically mixed people have like
oh my my mom's family was this so I used
to go to my you know if I I could have
said oh yeah my mom's Mexican and I used
to grow up go in my Thea's house or on
my white side I went to my aunt's house
I don't have that I didn't have that
growing up so I don't
I don't I can't identify with it why do
you why are you so mad at Mary for that
Mary didn't do anything yes you are yes
you are I can hear it when you when you
say I feel like I'm mad at myself
when you're embarrassed that you can't
speak Spanish there's a difference
between being embarrassed and wishing I
could
my kids know my sister is Tia Loca
I wish with all of my heart I was more
fluent in Spanish I could speak a lot
more than I actually can
I wish but I'm not mad at myself for it
my wife's taking it right now
she's incredible at it she just chose
one day I just this is just dumb to only
know a little bit of Spanish
and we do it for Hospitality purpose we
want to be able to speak to people in
our community that we hang out with that
are our friends that we love
and so it's a Hospitality thing for us
but it's not a matter of I should have
and I suck and they should have told you
see you see the anger and rage you got
on this
now imagine you're in algebra class
and there's somebody screaming in your
ear you should know this you're idiot
is that can you learn under that
condition
no no
well then how do I how
do you think I would be out of out of
line if I the next person who
uh treats me differently for not
speaking Spanish you think I should tell
them hey the reason why I don't speak
Spanish is because I wasn't raised in
the Mexican family you think that would
be too bold
I don't think it's too cold at all but
maybe no no What's it gonna solve
well I mean I think they should know I
sometimes I think they should know hey I
wasn't raised by a Mexican family I may
be Mexican ethnically but I wasn't
raised by a Mexican family and so will
that make you feel will that make you
feel better
I think so I think I think I don't think
I should keep it a secret I I should be
able to talk about it or if you just
said quietly I got adopted by a white
family
I'm getting to the point where I'm
starting to I think people should know
like you know I'm sorry it
I wasn't raising in Spanish-speaking
home
I wouldn't apologize for it
yeah
and I also implore you with all my heart
you gotta stop letting all these other
voices speak into who you are and what
your value is
you don't know these people
they're just neighbors clowning on you
an exercise that I did once that was
awful that ended up being amazing
was I want you to take up this is and
I'm passing it along to you this is your
homework assignment I want you to take a
small box
it could be a shoe box or it can be
something Fancy from a store I want you
to take a small box empty it out and put
it on your kitchen table this is just
you
and I want you to take out some note
cards
five of them
and I want you to write on the note card
the name of a person you are giving
permission to speak into your life
what I mean by speak in they get to tell
you
you shouldn't have done that
you just violated your core values
you need to take down that post off
social media that's what people in my
box are often telling me
you hurt me
they get to tell you those things
and if they're not in the Box your life
practice becomes
not caring what other people say and let
me be real honest with you I've taken my
parents out of my that box
I love them I've got great parents they
don't get a vote on how I raise my kids
they don't get a vote on what I should
or shouldn't be doing or what job I
should should be take that's not they
don't get a vote on that my in-laws
don't I love my in-laws I won the
lottery with my in-laws they don't get a
vote
I've got five friends and my wife
maybe six friends and my wife those are
the people I've given permission you
know who else doesn't have permission my
kids
because they're seven and thirteen they
can't buy beer yet so they don't get a
vote
right like we walk around especially
social media we walk around and we let
everybody else tell us what we should
and shouldn't be doing and feeling who
we should be hating and what skills we
should have and what skills we shouldn't
have and that's too Mexican that's not
Mexican enough oh and by the way when
you learn Spanish you're not going to
learn the right accent you're not you're
gonna you're gonna be a white Spanish
speaker right I already am I know and
then you're gonna be a white Spanish
speaker like you can't win that game
right right and I spent a lot of my
career studying inside of racial and
ethnic diversity
there's colorism within that
you're too dark of a Mexican you're not
you're too light you start playing those
games and you don't win and what you're
doing is you're taking you're
Outsourcing you to everybody else and
saying do I have value do I have value
do I have value
yeah
they don't get a freaking vote because
you're married from Bakersfield
and your parents
um your your bio lineage they let you
down and I'm so sorry
but from today forward as long as you
carry that that is you choosing I want
to wake up and have a more miserable day
I want to wake up and die a little bit
younger
because I couldn't set that down
and I want to set it down you have to
set it down you've got to make a choice
to set it down
I it can be as simple as this
once you go to to Home Depot or Lowe's
um and go buy a cinder block go purchase
one
purchase actually you probably need
three or four you've had a rough go
and I want you to take a
cinder block and put duct tape on it and
I want you to write mi madre and I want
you to carry that sucker around with you
until your arms are so achy and it's so
heavy
and to you kink I can't hold this any
longer
and then I want you to take it out in
your backyard and I want you to throw it
in the furthest corner and tear the tape
off and look at that thing and say I'm
never picking this up again
and what you will have done it's a tiny
little Annoying ceremony
kind of like a funeral if you will
you when you have a funeral you always
know that your loved ones is where they
are where they're buried their their
pain your pain is still in your heart
but you exhale there's a period at the
end of that sentence
and then at some point I want you to
write a letter to your mom
and ask her all of those questions what
was so bad about me
mm-hmm
write that letter to your dad you're not
going to send it this is for you I want
you to write a letter to that 14 year
old Mexican girl in a white ohioan home
Ohio and home
who felt has felt out of place her whole
life just lost at sea
and let her know she's amazing
see what I'm saying
your body's been at War since day one
but I I I I I my my prayer for you is
peace
I'm gonna I'm gonna send you a copy of
own your past change your future my book
okay I want you to read it start to
finish
and um it's just me my gift to you will
you read it if I send it to you yes yes
thank you okay
um
in about a month if you will practice
these things I want you to call me back
and I'll even have you back on the show
and listen if I have you back and you're
like oh I did all these things that you
said and you're stupid I will you can
tell the world this guy's a fraud he
doesn't know he's talking about
but if you'll do those things and you'll
keep a journal of all your negative
self-talk the shoulds I got to's I have
twos no I don't I'm freaking Mary from
Bakersfield I'm worth being loved and
this person who I don't know who just
stopped me and in line at a grocery
store and said something to me in
Spanish and I responded back no I'm like
espanol and
they made a face at me
I don't even know who they are
I'm not gonna let them ruin my day I
don't even know them I'm not going about
my day because I'm married from
Bakersfield
my life is good
choose peace Mary thank you so much for
being brave and thank you for the call
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back listen we've had
more and more people call in this year
who are struggling with issues and drama
and Mayhem in the workplace since 2021
we've seen four million people a month
leave their jobs political Economist
Nicholas eberstadt tells us that there
are seven million
million able-bodied men opting to sit at
home collecting government handouts
instead of working
I think there's more who have just opted
out of the system completely they're
just done
they just they just closed the laptop
and went home
so why are people giving all up on work
there's a drift to mediocrity plaguing
our culture because people aren't
finding meaning in their work anymore
Decades of bad leadership in Corporate
America
um decreased engagement at work quiet
quitting the great resignation and let's
be honest man I got buddies who are have
great jobs they've got great jobs and
they love their jobs and they can't
afford rent and groceries in the same
city
it's just a weird mess
productivity is down complacency is at
an all-time high and some of you are
listening might be stuck in the middle
of it all right now and this is this is
a non-partisan event
because I've Got Friends on both sides
of the aisle who are just about done
with it
on May 4th I'm teaming up teaming up
with Dave Ramsey can Coleman Mike Rowe
of Dirty Jobs Michael Easter um who's
the author of one of my favorite books
of the last decade Comfort crisis
um we're going to be talking about the
state of work in America today we're
going to address a labor crisis and give
Business Leaders solutions for how to
find and hire the right people in this
madness and here's the deal if you're
not a leader and you're not a boss this
is this is like getting backstage behind
the curtain and listening to How bosses
talk to other bosses
so you're going to get a Playbook on
what people are looking for what they
are desperate to have on who they're
desperate to have on their teams and
here's the best part of this whole
thing's free the whole thing is free if
you're a business leader small business
owner or you just want to figure out
what you're doing with your career you
gotta move it's time you want to do
something different whatever it is if
you're struggling right now you don't
want to miss this free live stream you
can register by visiting
ramseysolutions.com
labor crisis all right and so as we wrap
up usually we do lyrics at the end of
the day we're not doing that today we're
doing something new
this brought me so much joy that we
decided instead of doing lyrics I'm just
gonna make you make you smile before the
day's over
it's from CBS CBS feels like
it's from CBS Evening News teenagers
help seniors learn how to use technology
and they form friendships along the way
residents at Brookdale Senior Living
have a wealth of wisdom but there are
some gaps in that knowledge most notably
how do I turn on my cell phone
everything from turning on devices to
receiving emails connecting families to
finding relevant applications
posed trouble for the residents so
students
um at Canterbury School in Fort Myers
Florida were joking about it these are
high school kids about how bad their
grandparents were at Tech then when the
laughter faded a guy a young man named
Aaron said I have an idea
he got his friends together and they
started the computers computer literacy
education outreach program they
partnered with Brookdale
so they just showed up
they walked over there
and they started connecting with these
folks wisdom's being shared
relationships are being formed y'all
know I'm not a fan of Technology but
when she's right it can be magic in
these young men and women are are
changing lives
and here's the secret
those Folks at the senior living home
are changing lives too they're passing
that wisdom back down the system what A
rad idea don't tell me I don't know what
to do get on the phone and go find some
people who are in need and just show up
I love you guys and see you soon
[Music]